battle what was it how do you pass it oh
god Jim will get better coming up with
names for the alien places and people
and things
[Applause]
[Music]
series 11 finale the Battle of the Dibby
Dibby there so whatever it's called and
it's pretty good it's not amazing it's
kind of par for the course for this
series more often than not but I'm
probably gonna end up largely pretty
well disposed to the episode because I
finally had my eye
now get this doctor and I you know I
really kind of love her moment which
literally happened in the very last
thing that happened in the episode so
talk about waiting till the last minute
so yeah it was her getting in the TARDIS
and saying goodbye to the characters who
weren't kind of travel with them and you
know just sort of having that moment of
you know vici you know the universe can
surprise you and that's why you know I
keep traveling and it's not that that
line was expressing anything that like
The Dark Knight Express before but
there's something about saying that line
at the end of this adventure and the way
she delivered it it's something it
finally clicked like I felt before like
I didn't fully get this doctor I'm like
oh she's the joy in exploration doctor
cuz it helps for me when I can
categorize the doctors it was a big part
of why it took me a little while to get
Capaldi because I couldn't really
categorize him properly until his second
series so what I mean by that is you
know the I mean sometimes the yeah
sometimes they're given the labels by
the show itself but I mean you know the
night just going the new series the
night doctors the wounded soldier tenth
doctors lonely God eleventh Doctor's the
madman with a box twelfth doctor is the
aging rock star and this now is the this
is the joy in exploration doctor which
you know it took me a little while to
get there and there were hints of it and
actually it makes me kind of want to go
back and watch a series again to sort of
feel like see if I appreciate it more
now that I kind of
what the angle was on her so like it was
nice to finally have that moment so now
I'm actually looking forward much more
to getting more from her because we have
at the confirmation of series 12 and
when that's happening I'm actually gonna
do a whole separate video on that
because of course they drop that right
I'm gonna have a lot of Doctor Who
videos this week like a lot uh-huh so
just heads up on that
so anyways um so setting aside that I
finally got my moment of like there she
is with the doctor the episode overall
was I don't know I'm I'm debating I
haven't figured out how I'm gonna rank
the other episodes of this series yet
but right now it's competing with the
ghost monument for the Chibnall
written episode written by him hims
alone anyways that I like best it's
between the two of them and I think I'm
gonna have to rewatch ghost monument to
make the call on that because like most
of the things that are good and this are
things that have been good for the whole
series and the writing is not one of
them both oh I don't think the writing
is terrible here but I do feel like
almost every other element is picking up
the slack so like Marc addy great get
I'm not sure there was a ton to his
character but he brings a lot to a cuz
he's a really good performer it was
gorgeously shot Tim Shaw I actually came
to really appreciate that guy's
performance he's actually really good
and I love the voice modulation they did
on they did on him it felt really good I
just wish it had been a payoff on a
callback to a villain that had left more
of an impression on me then he did cuz
didn't leave that much so it was like as
he appears in this episode it's pretty
solid stuff I just wish it was calling
back to a villain whose first appearance
I thought better of it kind of reminds
me actually a little bit of what
happened with the with the return of the
great intelligence because the great
intelligence showing up in the snow man
I'm like ice fine but when he shows
again the following series and
especially how he's used in name of the
doctor I actually really liked but I
kind of wish it was calling back to a
villain who had better previous
appearances and I mean to be fair the
great intelligence was also a call back
to a classic era villain whose stories I
haven't seen yet so I mean there was
more going on than that but and so like
I'm really mixed on that and the whole
thing would be ox like okay seriously
Chibnall
you gotta find somebody else to come up
with these alien names cuz they stink
they're they're not memorable they're
generic they're just and they'll they
all just sit badly on my ear yeah the
stands are the Ox the Oh God
they're all kind of bad but solid track
yeah anyways I has a weird nitpicky
thing that's bugging me this this
bugging me this entire series but
seriously it's been to get a ping what
okay I'm getting off so in any case you
know the some of the other stuff is
going on here we've got the ox and the
concept behind them is kind of
interesting but then at the same time it
falls into a bit of a trope that I
really don't like which is easily shaken
faith so like I get like I feel I feel
like this episode overall should have
been a two-parter I feel like we needed
more time with the ox to to get a better
sense of their faith and how it worked
in why they had accepted Tim Shaw as
their creator as opposed to just the
sheer dumb coincidence that he showed up
there like oh it's him like that that I
don't love and then you know there's the
idea that their faith is shaken so
easily basically by the doctor just
talking them through it you know that's
that's always something that kind of
bothers because I mean that the nature
of faith as opposed to you know a belief
based in fact is it doesn't make
logical sense that's why it's faith as
opposed to you know a scientific process
so when somebody's faith gets shaken by
a logical argument it kind of annoys me
because like that's not how faith works
like and if you deeply believe this five
seconds ago somebody throwing this one
little thing is not gonna like throw
your brain completely off the off the
track I don't know it's this is act this
is but this is not even close to the
most egregious examples I've seen of
this kind of thing like the worst I can
think of off the top of my head go back
and watch well don't actually because
it's really bad but Tim Burton's Planet
of the Apes movie like a guy who has
been really into the legend of like the
foundation of his of the ape Society has
his faith shaken by being told that the
guy that that the founder of the society
they believed in wasn't a good guy he's
like what it's like what really lifelong
faith shaken by the word of one
so like I said what happens in this
episode not the worst example I've had
I've seen a bit but it's just a trope
that annoys me like the whole idea was
kind of cool with like the fact that the
planet was gonna mess with them but then
it never really does like they even set
it up where the doctor and yes take
their things off and there were really
consequences to that so it makes me
wonder why do you even have it as a
thing like was it just reverse
engineered so that they had these things
on their head so the doctor could stick
them on the ox and stop their mental
stuff going out like was that what
happened you thought well we need them
to have these devices well I don't want
to just have the doctor have them in our
pocket why could they be using them oh
because the planets like this like I
feel like that must be the thought
process because if you would come from a
starting point up they land on a planet
that messes with your head you wouldn't
have that have no impact on the story
and they
like on the dozens which is weird I
don't say with the return of Tim Shah
but pay off with with Ryan and Graham
worked well I specially actually I
really love Graham shooty give it rides
like hey like notes just in the foot I
just shot him in the foot come on he
deserved that
don't tell the doc like though that was
great
I mean grams just creams just awesome
and lovely so all that was really good
okay looks really good let this let's be
honest this whole series has been
gorgeously shot criticized the writing
all you want I don't think anybody has
any right to criticize the direction and
and the shooting of these of this series
it has been gorgeous to look at I mean
that doesn't fix the problems because
and I mean I don't know you know it
buries from person person your mileage
may vary for me I'm a story person first
I'd rather have a good story with it the
effects then a great-looking story that
is me I do think this episode is better
than men though but it does seem like
for a lot of the stuff that I like
there's a counterbalance to it that's
not necessarily totally negating it but
holding it back from being as good as it
should be
I also don't love that the earth got
threatened especially considering they
weren't even on the freakin planet oh
he's gonna destroy the earth sure why
not let's just threaten the earth cuz
that's what we always do in the finales
so even though we're gonna completely
plan it with personal stakes for the
characters based on a history of someone
they've had to deal with in the past
ya know sure let's threaten the earth
while we're here why not you know hey
yeah I I can't help but nitpick but is
out of frustration because there's a lot
to like in this episode there's a lot I
like about the interactions and the
performances are good and there's a lot
of neat build up the the condensed
planets is is kind of cool reminded me
of the pirate planet actually the fact
that
that came up I like that the doctor gave
a little call back you mentioned the
Saline turning into an egg that was fun
I think that's I mean just it wasn't it
wasn't the world's strongest finale but
it was a decent finish and it my it's
one of the better ones that Chibnall
himself wrote not the highest bar I am
regret to say I think ultimately the
thing and I'm gonna do a separate video
talking about this sort of an overview
of series eleven the the thing is is
that chip Knowles Chibnall does have
strengths but his strengths lie
primarily in character which is a lot of
what's good about this because I
mentioned you know the doctor I finally
had my moment with her Graham Ryan even
Tim Shaw is working as a character
because he's allowed to function a
little bit more as a character here at
least at least I felt like he was this
time but all of the sort of the other
stuff you know the how the the plot
mechanics it's it's not bad it's just
kind of there and unfortunately Doctor
Who is a show that kind of needs decent
plot mechanics or at least we tend to
expect them I don't know like I said
separate video talking about that plus I
got to do a video talking about the
dates for when series 12 is gonna air
plus I gotta do a video actually whiny
series 11 plus I've got overdue Doctor
Who video this honestly might be a week
of nothing would talk to who videos now
that I stop and think about it that's
not actually a bad thing it's just ah
not what I'd planned
in any case battle of bit did the baby
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments oh let's talk about a whole
bunch of something you do because
there's buttons and there's links
including one to my patreon if you want
to support the show that way it'd be
awesome if you did if you don't though
that's okay too there's other links to
check out and even if you don't want to
click on those that's alright too
because at the end of the
you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]